well welcome to the show today we're
just at the beginning of what's supposed
to be a major winter storm here in
nashville and by major winter storm i
mean like um you know four or five
inches or something but four or five
inches counts as a major storm around
these parts especially because of the
apocalyptic panic that grips hold of
everybody on the roadways as soon as one
single flake falls from the sky the
flake doesn't have to doesn't have to
fall from the sky actually i mean the
drivers around here if they see a flake
of of dandruff fall from
their own heads while they're driving
they'll still freak out and plunge right
into the nearest ditch what all that
means is that um i can't get on the
roads right now
because i value my life and so instead
of going to my normal studio i am back
in my original studio i'm getting in
touch with my roots today
back in the car
talking to my dashboard once again
thoroughly confusing my neighbor who
just walked out of his house
hey and was
obviously confused about what's
happening here now i could have recorded
in my house which i'm sitting right next
to right now in the driveway but the
problem is that all four of my kids are
home right now and the only way to keep
them quiet for an hour would be to
i don't know lock them in some sort of
soundproof box in the attic but
cps generally frowns upon that kind of
parenting strategy and so uh this is
what we're doing also it just it just
felt right it feels right to be here
again
in the car
so um
we start with this
if a lab in china has proven to be a
factory for viral contagions
um you know in the world
then the internet social media in
particular and especially tick tock is a
factory for a different kind of
contagion social contagion
destructive and degrading and
you know behaviors and lifestyle choices
concepts ideas can go from fringe to
trendy to mainstream quite literally
overnight right what was unusual one
minute might be ubiquitous the next and
people especially young people can get
caught in the current and drowned before
they even notice that their shoes are
wet here is perhaps the latest example
and maybe the strangest
also a very instructive example
over on tick tock there is apparently an
intense interest in multiple personality
disorder or did dissociative identity
disorder is what they call it now
hashtags related to this topic have
millions
of entries i mean hundreds of millions
of entries that's how that's how much
interest is that's how popular it is and
many of them are from users claiming to
have did themselves the trend has grown
large enough that even good morning
america has noticed and they did a
report on it a couple of days ago watch
this
now to the rise in teens on tick-tock
who are self-diagnosing themselves with
rare mental health disorders that they
probably don't have after watching
videos on the social platform it's a
story we first saw in the wall street
journal and ariel reshef joins us with
more on this ariel good morning
good morning to you matt mary those
videos have been viewed hundreds of
millions of times and while experts say
this may be elevating a conversation
about mental health self-diagnosis can
be a dangerous slippery slope
the id typically occurs between the ages
of six and nine this morning experts
warning about what they call a troubling
trend on tick tock that could leave some
teens believing they have a serious
mental disorder
host with the hashtag disassociative
identity disorder and borderline
personality disorder viewed hundreds of
millions of times some of those videos
listing possible signs to look out for
and encouraging viewers to self-evaluate
right so now in these videos and again
there are many of them
the alleged multiple personality
sufferer will will usually refer to
themselves as the system
that's how these people refer to the
they are the system
and the system is the word they use to
describe the whole collective of
personalities that they have in their
heads and then each individual
personality is called an altar
and they will then usually introduce
each alter in their videos each
personality and sometimes put on a
different voice for each one but that
requires a certain amount of talent that
most these people don't have um and so
most of the videos are kind of like this
one watch
hi my name's becca i'm the host of the
system
hi i'm bella i don't really know what
role i have in the system because
i am a new alter so
hello my name is rosa i am the caretaker
of the system
what's up it's jamie i'm the primary
protector of the system
we took our meds a while ago so i'm
groggy
hi my name's vega i am the sexual
protector of the system
hey i'm kai i am a trauma holder and
gatekeeper for the system i work very
closely with another alter nick
who is an internal uh caretaker he does
not really front
so you see that's how multiple
personality disorder works apparently um
all of the personalities are aware of
each other and and they work together
you know they hold meetings and
conferences they send memos back and
forth and emails and everything
this is what happens i guess when you
have 14 personalities and they're all
boring as hell
though some members of the alleged did
community on tik tok they do try to keep
things a little bit more interesting so
here's the guy whose personalities are
um are more antagonistic towards one
another which makes it more interesting
watch
hey everyone it's asher the best alter
this is dan the life of somebody that
has dissociative identity disorder let's
go
hi everyone it's annie and i'm gonna be
in charge of cleaning today
that means i'm going to be out i'm going
to be listening to my music and i get a
nice couple hours just to myself this is
really nice because i tried to get some
time out yesterday and i couldn't
and since i'm going to be out for a
little bit i changed into my clothes
this is my necklace and this is a shirt
somebody sent me everybody it's alex and
he got jalapeno in her eye and then
switched out immediately so i had to
switch in and now i'm having to deal
with the pain so thank you annie hi
everybody it's april this is the before
shot
and this is an aftershock this is why
i'm in control of what the body looks
like the boys would make it look
homeless
now
the impression of did that you get from
videos like this is that a person with
this disorder has sort of a cohort of
little gnomes or gremlins living in his
skull driving him around fighting for
control of the steering wheel and uh and
that's
most of the videos are like this and and
they've been extremely effective
in convincing other people on the site
mostly kids that they too can have
multiple personalities the problem of
course
there are a lot of problems
one of them is that is that this is how
split personalities work in movies and
tv shows not in real life
there was a best-selling book called
sybil back in the 70s i think they made
a movie uh about the book as well
and that that's that's the one that
first popularized this concept of
multiple personality disorder before
that
um it it existed as a clinical concept
but it wasn't it wasn't in the
mainstream the way that it is now
and in that book the patient sybil real
name shirley mason
has a condition that works kind of like
what you see in the tick tock videos
kind of like what you see in the movies
it was an m night shyamalan movie split
where the guy has 15 different
personalities and some of them are
serial killers and some of them aren't
um
and so
shirley mason sybil had something sort
of like that
problem though is the book was based on
a lie the whole thing was a hoax it was
a fraud
even so it's cemented into the minds of
the american public and and people
um this idea and people have been
convincing themselves that they suffer
from this fake version of the illness
ever since
now of course i say fake version of the
illness as if there's a real version
i don't think there is now this is very
much a live debate in the psychiatric
field right now
some so-called mental health experts
will argue that did exists but it's very
different from the
cinematic portrayals and others will say
that the whole thing is a category error
that it doesn't exist at all it's an
invention of the psychiatric field
itself
now according to this argument which i
find extremely persuasive
there's only a very very very small
number of patients who would even
potentially qualify for this diagnosis
and then among that small group a
certain portion of them are simply
faking it
that's the problem with with this mental
with a lot of mental illnesses in fact
that is that um despite what what you're
often told or what you what you might
think with a lot of these illnesses
uh they have not located the illness in
the physical brain itself
because if they had they wouldn't call
them mental unless they would call it a
brain disease or a neurological
condition
but those are distinct categories
so if they're calling a mental illness
it means that they have not
um
with any with any they have certainly
not conclusively located the illness
within the brain and if you haven't
located the illness physically
then it's really just theoretical
whether it physically exists or not
um
and so that's that's that's another idea
about multiple personality disorder that
it doesn't exist
that it's only a very very small group
of people who potentially would even
qualify for it many of them are faking
it and then there's also another portion
that have been conv they're not faking
it intentionally they've just been
convinced through cultural and
therapeutic influences that they have
the disorder when they really don't so
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
now at any rate it certainly can be said
that um those who believe in the
existence of legitimate multiple
personality disorder have never come
close to actually proving that it exists
all they can do is produce examples of
people who claim to have it which is far
from the sort of proof that they would
really need
is it even possible for a single mind to
contain
multiple distinct personalities distinct
minds within itself which are separate
from each other and not aware
of what the other is thinking how does
that even work
is it possible for a mind to be
compartmentalized in that way
um it's an extraordinary concept which
requires extraordinary evidence to prove
and none of that evidence has been
provided
but that's all somewhat academic right
whether split personalities exists or
not we can hopefully all agree that 10
million people on tick tock didn't all
suddenly start suffering from the
illness all at the same time
this trend is without a doubt a result
of both self-delusion
and deliberate fraud
and often kind of a mix of the two
maybe it begins as a deliberate fraud
and then people actually
succeed in convincing themselves that
they really have it
um i i used to be very good at this kind
of thing when i was a kid
when i would pretend that i was sick so
i didn't have to go to school
and then by late at late morning i'd
actually start feeling sick because i
was so good at acting the part and i
think something like that happens
sometimes with these mental illnesses
now the more interesting and important
question
is why exactly
so many people would want to convince
the world and themselves that they
suffer from what would be a debilitating
mental illness i think there are a few
answers to that
one is the most obvious point
that the mentally ill are a victim class
victimhood is is power in our culture as
we know the more victim labels you can
claim the more power the more social
credit you accrue
also too
many people lack anything approaching a
real identity or a real personality
mostly because they've been staring at
screens every waking moment of their
lives and letting the internet do all
their thinking for them
and
they have almost no internal dialogue
they have no almost no internal life at
all
and because of this
you know they tend to adopt a quantity
over quality approach to personality
usually this will come in the form of
adopting different pronouns different
sex and gender identities but this
latest thing is even better because it
allows them to literally take on more
than one personality
all of the personalities are dull and
uninteresting
but they but what they lack in substance
they make up for in sheer numbers i
guess
three related to this
mental illness in general is especially
trendy in its own right largely for the
reasons covered by the first two points
and four this all stems from our
fundamentally disjointed and essentially
superstitious view of the self
so we see the self
ourselves
the self
generally not as a continuous holistic
coherent thing
but as an arbitrary amalgamation
of our desires and our hopes and our
preferences in any given moment
we're constantly in the process of
uncreating and recreating ourselves
our self of five minutes ago doesn't
necessarily bear any relation to our
self of right now and our self of right
now
may be entirely different from the self
that takes the field tomorrow
we see ourselves
in this culture today as these kinds of
um
shape-shifting changelings
lacking any concrete overriding
identity and according to this view of
things
really we all have dissociative identity
disorder
because it's easy to dissociate from an
identity when you don't really have one
at all to begin with
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends